two ladies who definitely have the
spirit sherry shepherd and kim whitley
you can always count on those two for
some real talk especially
about being a parent okay a little best
and worst
about being cooped up at home this whole
time
the best thing about being cooped up
when i have a teenage son that i've
gotten to know
[Laughter]
i said i wanted to come out as a better
person i've lost 25 pounds
stand on up stand up and be cute let's
call it oh
and that right there is a little taste
of sherry and kim's next level chemistry
in their podcast two funny mamas
what's the slogan of the side peace
union
we help you be number two
are you dating during this time are you
like literally i had a virtual date
where we watched
dexter together and we face time i've
been waiting a long time for this
yeah it was a little bit of a red flag
because he was the one that suggested
watching dexter together and i said i'm
i'm not quite sure about
this but i'm lonely these two funny
mamas are also teaming up tomorrow for
cw's variety show special women in film
presents
make it work so we want to be involved
to help
and also shine a light on hey people who
are in power
hire women yeah i'm a big
proponent on sharing your experience
with other women even
with the salary rosie o'donnell helped
me negotiate my
salary on the view what they offered me
was so low and then rosie o'donnell came
in and said uh-uh sister
this is what i'm making this is what you
need to ask for another thing i always
tell women
never take the first offer that's just a
man
okay i'm sorry and even then you're not
supposed to take the first offer kim
hey at a certain age share ain't nobody
[Music]
waiting
you